he's considered the first blood king his
skills have earned the respect of
junglers everywhere he's captured
back-to-back LEC titles and he's won MSI
and on Sunday he's poised to make
history this is that the greatest team
history of League of Legends
taken down by the greatest team Europe
has ever produced BX get ready
g2 if you didn't already guessed I'm
talking about yang COEs Europe's MVP
jungler has spent the last year
dominating League and now he is one
series away from becoming a world
champion yet cost the first king yank
owes his career hasn't always been this
great before this year he was the best
European player to never win since
joining the EU LCS in 2014 Yanko sis
bounced from Roccat to h2k before
joining g2 in 2018 but from the moment
yang coast joined the league it was
clear that this guy was something
special bowls antennae really carefully
a cyanide coming around the side I think
so it's gonna go down first put those
over to yank us once again sided idea
he's gonna be held together killed by
though on tasers to trade war for one
run again yeah coughs first blood master
although yang Coast didn't have any
titles to brag about his talent was
undeniable bender a little bit to lower
this one is just
[Applause]
and more than that
Yanko Spain a name for himself with his
larger-than-life personality I mean this
dude is always ready to crack a joke
Tiberian is really outperforming new but
the glutes he cannot do the doors his
book is it a beautiful still or what
Fabian cannot outperform you oh but this
year yankles was unlocked
this g2 lineup is far and away the best
team yankles has ever played for with
nutty laners to complement his style
yankles felt unstoppable i think that my
team's when I started my career were not
as strong as t2 is right now I feel like
since I know so much about the game
right now
I know what to do in every situation and
even if I don't I can count on my team
to help me out
g2 feels like the perfect place for yang
COEs he can go nuts and play that
aggressive style that everybody knows
him for or he can join his team in some
creative cops g2 are going Morgana pike
and a funnel come this was the
opportunity of yonkers his lifetime and
he made sure not to waste it
[Applause]
before this year yang kosis trophy case
was empty but now he has the accolades
to back up his stellar play and there
are no more questions
yang cos is undoubtedly Europe's best
jungler I mean he's the best jungler
that Europe has ever produced period the
reason he's so smart is not just his
ability in game not just his ability to
adapt to multiple champions but also he
truly understands his solo lanes the
only title he's missing is a world's
trophy and if g2 are able to lift the
summoner's Cup but be the first team to
sweep an entire year of pro league the
community has started to call it the g2
Grand Slam and at this point it's
looking pretty likely that they'll do it
yang Coast is having an insane world's
run and he's done it against some of the
best junglers in the world and the
group-stage yankles had to face off
against Griffin's all-star jungler
Tarzan and after yang Coase was clowning
around on stream g2 fans were kind of
worried about how the game against
Griffin is going to go we did that
scream some Asian themes and the game
not good by the game and fans were right
to be worried because despite g2 winning
the first game Griffin beat them
back-to-back sending the European
champions down to their group second
seed and it's in those losses that
Tarzan got the upper hand over yang COEs
after we lost against Griffin we took
screams way more seriously and I feel
like that way we improved a lot of the
team driving the main issue is that I
was running down against Griffin after
making it out of groups janko's
continued to face off against some of
Korea's best junglers in the
quarterfinals he played against Canyon
one of Dan Wong gaming's rookie stars
on to the semi-finals for the FS I'd
rematch vs. SKT the last of the lck
versus the last of the ABC
following that win yankles faced even
stiffer competition clip in the last
year [ __ ] has made a name for himself as
Korea's best jungler alongside Tarzan
but here's the thing
ankles already been cleared at msi
earlier this year and five months later
history repeats and janko's was named
player of the game after the series move
on to the Oppo player of the game there
was some contention there was some
debate but in the end it was a water - G
- yen cost the only jungler left
standing in yang kosis way his fun quest
phoenix is tanned and let me tell you
guys this dude is no slouch Holland's
gonna get quote by the dredge line and
the shy takes so much
display superior white Bianco's tan is
also having a crazy run at world his
jungling ability is what allowed join b2
just absolutely pop off that's a flash
bullet and crisp resemble to sidestep a
lot of the damage manages to get the
trash I guess the support from display
for a triple kill but you would be
despite fun plus Phoenix's strengths a
lot of analysts are predicting a g2 win
and if g2 does win it will be the first
European title in modern league history
the last time they won was in season one
and that was in 2011 a lot of regions
didn't even have servers yet for yang
Coast winning a world championship would
complete one of the most legendary years
any players had in professional league
of legends in history it's safe to say
that there's a lot of pressure but the
amazing thing about g2 is you wouldn't
know it by looking at them they're going
into these finals the same way they went
into Worlds laughing smiling and willing
to try anything
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]